y
[Música]
joe biden presentó un plan de 1,9
billones de dólares para reactivar la
economía estadounidense
las propuestas sujetas a la aprobación
del congreso buscan administrar 100
millones de vacunas en sus primeros 100
días en la presidencia expandir pruebas
de el coronavirus aumentar el salario
mínimo y nuevos pagos de 1.400 dólares
para todos los estadounidenses el
coronavirus sigue causando estragos y
alcanzando niveles del pasado marzo
cuando fue declarado como pandemia en
europa donde 6 países están entre los 10
más afectados del mundo la agencia afp
reporta más de 30 millones de casos y se
endurecen las restricciones en américa
la ciudad de la amazonía brasileña
manaus vive un colapso sanitario y en
asia los rebrotes en china igualan los
máximos de marzo
el presidente de argentina alberto
fernández firmó ayer el decreto para la
promulgación de la ley del aborto
aprobada el 30 de diciembre por el
senado una legislación que según el
mandatario permitirá crear una sociedad
más igualitaria y más justa
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria
empezamos en eeuu donde el presidente
electo joe biden anunció un plan de
rescate de 19 billones de dólares para
impulsar la economía y acelerar la
respuesta frente a la pandemia es un
proyecto que ahora debe ser aprobado por
el congreso y llega cuando faltan cinco
días para que el demócrata se posicione
en la casa blanca más en este informe
en campaña prometió tomarse a la
pandemia de kobe 19 más sencillo que su
rival ahora con un plan de estímulo de
19 billones joe biden dice que es el
momento de pasar a la acción
price es una crisis de profundo
sufrimiento humano está a plena vista
y no hay tiempo que perder tenemos que
actuar y tenemos que actuar ahora now la
propuesta de bailén incluye 415 mil
millones de dólares para combatir la
crisis sanitaria que se ha cobrado la
vida de más de 388.000 estadounidenses
el presidente de elektro describe la
actual distribución de la vacuna como
una farsa dice que espera que durante
sus primeros 100 días en el cargo haya
100 millones de inoculaciones el plan es
entregar 20 mil millones para centros de
vacunación comunitarios y unidades
móviles unos 50.000 millones serían para
ampliar las pruebas y otros 130.000 se
destinarán a la reapertura de las
escuelas además de combatir la pandemia
vall d'en afirma que también hay que
tener en cuenta sus consecuencias su
paquete de ayuda incluye un billón de
dólares para los hogares estadounidenses
con pagos directos de 1.400 dólares a
todos sus ciudadanos esto se suma a los
cheques de 600 dólares de ayuda
aprobados en diciembre
además el demócrata quiere aumentar el
salario mínimo a 15 dólares por hora y
entregar 15 mil millones en subsidios de
cuidado infantil a familias de bajo
ingresos y sé que lo que acabo de
describir no será barato pero si
fracasamos nos costará caro asistirle
maiden asegura que hacen falta
inversiones audaces para hacer despegar
la economía pero se espera que muchos
republicanos en el congreso se opongan a
estos costos aunque el presidente electo
cuenta con que los demócratas tendrán el
control de la cámara y el senado
se superaron los 93 millones de casos
acumulados por la pandemia en el mundo y
una tercera parte de esos contagios
globales se reportan en europa que
rebasó los 30 millones de casos según el
recuento de la agencia afp seis países
de este continente están entre los diez
más afectados del mundo tanto en
contagios como en muertes por la
pandemia en contagios lideran rusia y el
reino unido- que sobrepasan ampliamente
los tres millones de casos el país de
boris johnson registra además la mayor
cifra de muertes en europa más de 86.000
seguido de italia que tiene 80.000
francia se acerca a los 3 millones de
contagios y a los 70 mil muertos el
gobierno francés anunció una nueva
ampliación del toque de queda nacional
las autoridades del reino unido
prohibieron el ingreso a su territorio
de viajeros procedentes de al menos 14
países sudamericanos por la aparición de
una nueva variante del virus en brásil
escuchamos al ministro británico de
transporte
hay una prohibición de viajar desde
brasil y en realidad creo que otros 14
países sudamericanos y también portugal
porque existe una nueva variante hemos
visto esto
antes hay miles de ellas por supuesto
pero algunas de ellas se transmiten más
fácilmente son obviamente de mayor
preocupación y a nivel mundial han
fallecido 1,99 millones de personas y
más de una tercera parte de esas muertes
se acumulan en tres países americanos
eeuu brasil y méjico brasil registró más
de mil muertes por tercer día y superó
los 207 mil fallecimientos el ministerio
de salud brasileño admitió un colapso
por el que pasa a la salud pública en el
estado de amazonas principalmente en
manaus la capital regional por su parte
méxico registró la semana con mayor
mortalidad desde que comenzó la pandemia
con un promedio de 983 fallecimientos
diarios desde el 7 de enero según las
más recientes cifras oficiales de este
jueves el gobierno mexicano reporta más
de 137 mil decesos
en indonesia al menos 35 personas
muertas deja un terremoto de magnitud 6
2 en la isla de sulawesi también
conocida como célebes también se
reportan cientos de heridos y decenas de
viviendas dañadas alrededor de 2000
personas fueron evacuadas a refugios
temporales y siguen las labores de
búsqueda y rescate por parte de las
autoridades mientras que la cruz roja
advierte de la dificultad de realizar
estas tareas en medio de una pandemia
que deja hoy récord de contagios en este
país
el número de casos positivos se ha
disparado últimamente en indonesia
tenemos suerte de no tener hasta donde
sabemos esta nueva variante pero no se
puede ayudar a los demás mientras estás
en peligro y poner en riesgo a otras
personas
necesitamos encontrar el equilibrio
entre por un lado brindar servicios a
las personas y por el otro asegurarnos
de que las personas que enviamos estén
bien protegidas nos vamos a argentina el
presidente alberto fernández firmó la
ley de interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo que permitirá que las mujeres
puedan abortar de forma segura y legal
hasta las 14 semanas de embarazo es el
cuarto país de américa latina en aprobar
esta legislación y su vecino chile
podría ser el siguiente vamos a este
informe de luís muñoz
cuidado una firma que da inicio a una
nueva era para las mujeres argentinas
con el lema es ley
el presidente alberto fernández llevó a
cabo el último trámite para la entrada
en vigor de la legislación de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
después de que a finales del pasado año
el congreso y el senado hubiesen
aprobado la norma se trata de uno de los
grandes hitos de la legislatura
hoy es un día de felicidad para todos
porque lo que estamos haciendo es una
sociedad un poco más igualitaria un poco
más justa algunos estados conservadores
han pedido la inconstitucionalidad por
lo que la corte suprema tendrá que
revalidar la norma pese a todo argentina
se une otros países como cuba guyana
uruguay y algunos estados mexicanos con
la ley se pone fin a años de protestas y
reivindicaciones de la ya histórica
marea verde las mujeres podrán abortar
en las primeras 14 semanas de embarazo
garantizando una interrupción legal y
segura esta ley viene a dar respuesta a
un gravísimo problema de salud pública
que tenemos en argentina hasta ahora que
es el aborto clandestino así han dejado
su vida
más de 3000 mujeres dice que recupera
cuánta democracia después de argentina
podría llegar el turno del vecino chile
que el miércoles inició la discusión de
un proyecto para despenalizar el aborto
en las primeras 14 semanas
el gobierno se opone pero el ejemplo de
argentina y la nueva constitución en el
horizonte pueden convertir a chile en el
siguiente país de américa latina en
lograr que la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo sea legal y la fiscalía
general de méxico anunció que no
procesará penalmente al ex ministro de
defensa salvador cienfuegos extraditados
desde eeuu donde estuvo precio entre
octubre y noviembre eeuu sachs a
cienfuegos de cuatro delitos de
narcotráfico y lavado de dinero por
supuestamente haber ayudado al cártel h2
a traficar miles de kilos de cocaína
heroína metanfetamina y marihuana la
autoridad mexicana aseguró que el
general nunca tuvo un encuentro con los
integrantes de la organización delictiva
y que no hallaron otras pruebas que lo
incriminen
luego de analizar los elementos
probatorios enviados por las autoridades
norteamericanas y los aportados por el
general salvador cienfuegos la fiscalía
general de la república concluyó que él
no sostuvo encuentro ni comunicación con
grupo delictivo alguno por lo que se
determinó no ejercer acción penal 17
millones de ciudadanos ugandeses fueron
llamados a las urnas este jueves en las
elecciones presidenciales y legislativas
el actual mandatario yoweri museveni
lleva la delantera según los resultados
preliminares aunque su principal rival
el cantante y opositor bobby wine señaló
un fraude y dijo que sus partidarios
tenían derecho a protestar wine no ha
presentado pruebas aún museveni que
busca su sexta reelección lleva el 63,9
por ciento de los sufragios mientras que
bobby wine 28,4 según la comisión
electoral que lleva 29 4% de los votos
escrutados
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que siga con
nosotros en france24 ya que se cuide del
'hobbit' 19
[Música]